last night I initiated official lockdown
procedure that's right
has gotten real no one is allowed
in or out of the bunker
besides my opponent tonight musician and
visual artist Kim Gordon yes she's
promoting the film don't worry he won't
get far on foot I hope she finds her way
through my trap maze because opposers we
are in this together
together we will fight back against the
forces trying to shut down truth and
devour America but first we gotta sell
some great products it's the shop
position fire sale look if they have
their way tomorrow is our last show so
we're here to sell you some products to
help you navigate the globe of fascist
news cycle without us and now I've never
lied to you yet this episode and I'm not
gonna start now this has nothing to do
with us needing money or my numerous
gambling debts this is about helping you
just like my buddy Alex Jones over at
Infowars he makes around seven to twelve
million dollars a year selling diet
supplements alone more than enough to
settle one of his many lawsuits and we
have ten times the deals he does let's
take a look at these incredible deals
Laura Grey what amazing products do you
have oh you're gonna love this Jordan we
here at the shop position know the best
way to get ready for a fight is to stay
ready and nothing keeps you ready or
than fear but what happens if you aren't
just naturally afraid of nearly
everything that's when you need shop
position brand fear goggles these
goggles are specially designed to keep
your anxiety high so you can see the
truth it's not a professional athlete
kneeling to protest police brutality
just slip on your goggles and OH
it's blatant disrespect for the flag and
a violent protest against America oh hey
is that two black men calmly sitting in
a Starbucks beer goggles on and looking
good Laura and remember opposers if you
don't see a threat you're just not
looking hard enough
Kokila be what incredible shot position
product do you have for us a Jordan I'd
like to report a criminal he is a man
[Applause]
fun fact opposers Laura's called 911 at
least 27 times which is all the proof
you need that those goggles work you
know what else works like a cursed demon
charm our shop ization brand slippery
slope and slide you'll have hours of fun
in the Sun while learning to make the
best kind of argument the slippery slope
kind at the top of the slide we see a
peaceful immigrant family entering the
US but soon your local Burger King
starts selling empanadas your child has
a play date with someone named Julio and
before you know it my god what's that a
group of vicious ms-13 gang members
watch out those face tattoos might bite
when you whizz down this baby you'll
find yourself sliding down a mental
slope into refreshing splash tastic
xenophobia
it's almost July get yours now also
available in gay marriage leads to pay
oh no this is a must-have for summer and
the sale price of just $49.99 is lower
than Mike Pence when he lovingly ties
the president's shoes every morning Erin
and Josh looks like you've got a really
big deal over there yes Jordan we are a
very big deal because we make everything
a big deal if it's something we care
about like remember when the Boy Scouts
decided to let girls in and lives were
all like whoohoo and we were all like
but it's the Boy Scouts
and they were all like is that the hill
you want to die on and we were like yes
yes on our one-of-a-kind hill to die oh
no too small to make a cute deal over
not enough people saying Merry Christmas
died on that hill I have to think for
two seconds about your preferred
pronouns give that guy a TV Oscar
suppose he'll to die on today Tucker
Carlson I'm looking at you the perfect
prop for what you naturally do every
night but how great products keep flying
off the shelves
Tim bolts tell us how many satisfied
composers we've got dozens Jordan dozens
of thousands the shop positioning box is
jammed with glowing reviews like this
one for our chi and heart accelerator
pills dr. Richard Jenkins writes this
product is fatal at any dosage one star
that's one star the best kind of star
okay everyone I'm sure what he really
means it's fatally great at keeping you
alerts tomato potato Jordan the point is
that last product will kill you let's
move on to another satisfied customer
this review is for our shop position
brand boom condenser Rupert nineteen
ninety Rupert nineteen boy
Rupert 1955 rights pill size is way too
big don't know how this is supposed to
fit up there one star nice big that's it
up product reviews for now suppose errs
this is serious we're under attack and
with our show going off the air you need
these products so you can fight the
globalists on your own there's nothing
strange about a media outlet making you
afraid than selling you products to
profit off that fear Alex Jones tells
you tap water is feminizing man then
goes ahead and sells you male vitality
supplements that seems awfully
convenient to you maybe you're just not
seeing things clearly in fact you know
what let me bring out my trusty gas
lights yeah look at that gas light you
think I'm making up problems and then
selling you the solution your brains
just broken good thing I sell brain
fixer pills now unselfish opposition
calm is this ghastly getting bigger buy
my drugs get on board
who doesn't like pills yummy yummy in my
tummy a pills make Danny go broom broom
don't question it you need them we're at
war how do you know I already told you
look at the gas light it by the gas
light
with five reasonable payments of 29
six wow that is a tail open opposers and
we need you to win this fight the fight
continues
the fight continues good you hid down
here with a real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe and
help me defeat them because following me
on my youtube channel makes you a leader
it tracks trust me